- When you meditate, we're
all human, we're all mortal.
When you meditate on your own mortality,
having achieved a lot of
success on whatever dimension,
what do you think is
the meaning of it all,
the meaning of our short existence
on Earth as human beings?
- I think that evolution
is the greatest force
in the universe, and
that we're all tiny bits
of an evolutionary type of
process where it's just matter
and machines that go through
time, and that we all have
a deeply embedded inclination
to evolve and contribute to evolution.
So I think it's to personally evolve
and contribute to evolution.
- I could have predicted
you would answer that way.
It's brilliant and exactly right.